September is here and that means you get
to go back to school observe the
autumnal equinox and get some free games
from PlayStation Plus but is it worth
renewing your subscription for let us
begin with velocity 2x the sequel to
velocity ultra which is the sequel to
velocity each time they've been adding
something new 2x adds a platforming
counterpart to this shmup but to be
honest with you you'll probably just
like the fast arcade shooting teleport e
action from your ship so yeah
moving right along we check out sports
friends a straight-up wacky
solid-colored series of games to play
with your buddies barabara ball is like
smash bros and volleyball smooshed
together pick your favorite friend and
go to on to force the ball down on the
other side but it's trickier and funnier
than you think you'll also enjoy the
coop like super pole riders where you
know what the goal is but you just can't
make your body do what you tell it to
these two alone make the game worth
playing but they also threw in the
competitive square hoarding okra and the
best living room party game since
twister johann Sebastian joust HYFR
action
am I going crazier is that Nathan Drake
vs. Sly Cooper well in must be
PlayStation all-stars battle royale
you'll enjoy fighting Raiden Kratos and
Big Daddy just as long as nothing
happens to sac boy because sack boy is
the shiz also PS plus errs get to be the
dragon in horde as first documented by a
bunch of hobbits years ago dragons are
all about the gold and they can never
have enough my favorite part is
kidnapping princesses and fending off
all the white knights that try to rescue
her for maximum profit in all honesty
that dragon is defending her because she
never asked to be saved get out of here
you stupid nights and lastly Vita get
some games with joe danger which has the
best levels ever because they're made by
you go support the devs that are working
on no man's sky by playing a completely
different type of game but seriously
this game is wicked fun and hours of
entertainment easy and finally we get
tempest on crack with txk a wildly
colorful space shooter that motivates
you with sick beats in support of text
like yes yes yes and pleasure mm-hmm
that's space motivation for you so take
a sick day and grab your eye speculums
because you got some video game homework
to finish mr. don't mess with the bull
young man you'll get the horns
you